the biggest culprit is this time where
you don't even know what you're doing
there's not a good way to describe it
and when I've had people do this they'll
write hours of time no recollection like
what happened was I abducted I don't
know we were doing something it passed
it was there but it wasn't memorable it
wasn't particularly enjoyable it was
just time and I think that's often the
biggest culprit for many people
why do you think it is that people are
so overwhelmed when it comes to time
management what's the problem that
they're trying to solve
for most of us is that time keeps past
passing no matter what you do and so it
is incredibly hard to spend time
mindfully no matter what you do a week
from now a week will have passed and so
getting you know ourselves in the place
where we can step back and and direct
that time as much as possible is is
challenging especially as life keeps
swirling around us so you know I'm
always on the lookout for ways that can
help people kind of calm this chaos
around us and make sure that we have
something of a say in where our time is
going one of the common threads that
I've found between a bunch of different
conversations that I've had recently
whether it's been to do with time
management or dating how you're supposed
to find your partner or productivity and
focus and attention and stuff like that
is intentionality that seems to be one
of the most common what you could call
it whatever you want right like effort
directionality Focus like being
intentional with how you do the thing
and it seems like there are a lot of
ways more than ever ways a censorium of
opportunities that we have to be
distracted by tons of things
I think we lay a lot of problems at the
feet of the modern 21st century I the
biology hasn't changed just the options
have but intentionality seems to be like
the thing that can cut through it all
absolutely although I'd argue that you
know life isn't really that different
um you know people have always wasted
time
um people have always felt busy I uh at
various points in my life have collected
old magazines
um you know from the 1950s and 1960s and
as you can imagine many of the articles
are on how people feel very busy and you
know modern life is just so crazy and of
course now people like but they didn't
have smartphones they didn't have you
know internet access like what happened
I don't know your boss can call you at
home like if they had phones that could
happen or people got stuck at the office
late or you know we have to fill time
with something and so you can feel
oppressed by whatever is going on in
your life even if some future version of
the world has entirely different
distractions so yeah you know we've
always managed to waste time we've
always felt like life can just happen to
us we've always needed to take steps to
to feel more in charge of our decisions
and our time in order to spend life a
little bit better
there's a story that I heard about
ancient Greece and the ancient Greek
word for work
ancient Greek word for work was
translated as not at leisure
and I thought that was very interesting
that the Greeks or work as an aberration
they saw that as the thing that was the
outlier and that Leisure Time was the
thing that was the set point for
Humanity and now that's kind of been a
little bit inverted but yeah you're
right I mean you know you can go back I
was learning about uh when bicycles were
first invented and it meant that women
could go out of the house without a
chaperone and the fact that women could
go out of the house without The
Chaperone was going to cause havoc and
this lady cycled in trousers and
everybody was Open Arms even worse their
legs were on oppos the sides of the bike
I couldn't believe how sexualized this
woman was as she she wore trousers she
was appropriating male uniforms or
whatever so yeah you're right
um it's a very easy get out of jail free
card for every generation to lay their
challenges at the feet of something that
previous generations didn't have to deal
with
at the moment it appears that we still
have 24 hours in a day as people always
have and uh you know the weeks weeks are
a human invention but days and years are
not so
um you know we've we've been dealing
with this for a while have weeks always
had seven days in
well that's a I mean if you think like
the biblical
um seven days of creation in the seven
day cycle of the Sabbath
um that's where sort of that idea comes
from there there are some cultures that
have sort of a different repeating cycle
like the market day is the every every
fifth day right and so they have a cycle
of five days but
people are listening to this podcast
you're at a place where you have seven
days in a week so uh that's uh that
that's most likely the case you've
looked at thousands of people's
schedules you've looked at what the most
successful people do on the morning
about how women can be a mother and have
a career in time management and not
drown in it and all that stuff what do
you think most people get wrong when it
comes to managing their time what are
the most common major errors that they
make
well one of the biggest errors is not
knowing how much time there is uh we we
live our lives in weeks we talked about
this being a human invention but it's a
very useful one this is how most people
structure their lives
um you know Tuesday and Saturday are
both typical days and that they both
happen just as often
um but you know your life probably looks
different on a Tuesday and a Saturday
whereas a week contains both of those so
as a week is a is a better vision of
your life but most people don't even
know that there are 168 hours in a week
right that is a number that people do
not have on the top of their heads it's
24 7 people say 24 7. they do not
multiply it through but the problem of
not even knowing this number is that we
have all sorts of ideas of how much time
we devote to different things in a week
but if we don't even know the
denominator it's kind of hard to get you
know adequate senses of proportions for
different things I mean just as one
example I think a lot of people assume
you don't have a lot of time for other
things right because it's full it's full
time it's right there in the name but if
you work 40 hours a week so pretty
standard full-time job sleep eight hours
a night so that is 56 hours per week
subtract those from 168 you got 72 hours
for other things which is almost twice
as much time as you are working I mean
it's just but people don't think that
way right so it's it's uh you know it's
the intentionality thing but it's also a
data piece that's missing and so that's
one of the reasons I always suggest
people do try tracking their time for a
week because many people are just
surprised to see where the time is
um where it goes how much time they're
sort of unclear what they're actually
doing with it because it's spent on you
know random stuff that hasn't
necessarily been actively chosen or
noticed or particularly enjoyed is that
most of the time that people are
surprised that I can't believe I spent
so much time doing
is that a lot of the time phone TV
screens it certainly can be I mean I
know many of us have had the experience
um that moment of truth if you have the
screen time app on your iPhone for
instance that it sends you a message in
my case Sunday morning I'm often uh in
the little bit of time I have before my
choir rehearsal and this Sunday morning
the church service starts and I'm
getting a ding on my phone telling me
you watch three hours of screen time
every day and I'm like what where did I
do this you know I don't remember that
happening but you know I did I'm sure
it's not making it up
um and and I think a lot of us have had
that experience that it's more time than
we might think but but it's far from the
only culprit I think you know there's
obviously you know things at work people
spend a ton of time like randomly
checking email
um people spend a lot of time in
meetings that maybe didn't even have to
happen or could have been shorter but I
think the biggest culprit is this time
where you don't even know what you're
doing like how would you even describe
it you're not there's not a good way to
describe it
um and when I've had people do this like
you know they'll write like hours of
time no recollection like what happened
was I abducted like who I don't know we
were doing something it passed it was
there but it wasn't memorable it wasn't
particularly enjoyable it was just time
um and and I think that's often the
biggest culprit for many people
for the people that have got iPhones
that have updated it to the most recent
iOS there's a way that you can make your
screen time become a widget on your home
screen and what that means is that
rather than I mean it's in the ass end
of your settings right you're not going
you're not going into that you get the
weekly screen time report which makes
you depressed for one day a week but if
you want to make yourself depressed
every day of the week
like you can create a widget uh and you
can have it and it'll show you the time
and it'll continue to do that also there
is another function let me just going
down lifx Route here
um
sleep now links up with people that if
you use a whoop or presumably if you use
a Fitbit or something else that'll Link
in with apple health and you can create
a sleep widget as well which tells you
every single day how much sleep you got
last night and it just it's just there
so for those things I think screen time
and sleep two pretty good examples I'm
sure we're going to talk about more
today as well that it's a nice reminder
whenever you go on your phone it just
reminds you like oh yeah you did good
last night you did good yesterday you
the habits that you're doing are working
or it gives you a kick if you yeah a
little kick if that's what you need if
you didn't quite so much yeah you've got
this quote that says we don't build the
lives we want by Saving Time we build
the life we want and then time saves
itself what's that mean
well
do you want to spend more time doing so
when it comes to time you know people
like time management I need hacks right
I need ways to shave bits of time off
everyday activities and I guess the idea
is that but we can add all those little
bits of time up and we will magically
create these wonderfully awesome lives
um which you know is somewhat ridiculous
if you think about it I mean one of the
hacks I've seen out there is like if you
send a lot of emails where the answer is
okay just type K instead of Okay and
like great like but even if I'm sending
hundreds of emails a day if I'm typing K
instead of okay does that all of a
sudden mean I have an awesome life like
no it does not you know there's another
step in there
um and and that other step is figuring
out what you want to spend time on
um so maybe we know what we don't want
to spend time on but what actively do
you want to fill your 168 hours with and
you know that takes some work to figure
out there's obviously the things we have
to do but there's also things we want to
do what are those things
um and if you actively try to put more
of those in your life they tend to crowd
out some of that space of nothingness
that we talked about not even clear what
you are doing and I've certainly seen
this in my own life I mean I mentioned
singing in this church choir and I a
couple years ago I I've loved to sing in
the past and I hadn't done it for a few
years and I was like well I'd like to
get back into it I'm like wow you know
how is this going to work I've got you
know four small children like I've got a
job where do you find the time and then
I'm like looking at my time and most
most of the evenings are just this like
nothingness it's like half kid
interaction kind of hoping they're
watching TV so I can put around the
house and do something else and like you
know I could probably Skip One Night of
that and like they'd still have me
puttering around while they're watching
TV or whatever like six out of seven
nights but that one night could be
something else and and you know so I put
it in and and it's not always easy to
get to rehearsal but
more or less I could fit it in it just
took some of that low value time away
and filled in something better and so
when you're trying to think about how we
can do that like if you you know decide
on the weekend to go do some fun
adventure you're gonna go with friends
to an apple orchard and you know pick
apples and then taste all their ciders
and something like that something
wonderfully fall oriented like yeah you
might not spend as much time like
sweeping your floor
like you might not spend as much time
getting caught up on email over the
weekend but like probably you'll answer
what you have to and like you'll pick up
any you know really obvious dirt
um and you will have had your adventure
too it like just pushed everything out
so we don't build the lives we want by
Saving Time with these little hacks
typing K instead of okay in our emails
we build the lives we want and then you
know everything else sorts itself around
that did you get familiar with the trend
of tech Bros and crypto people refusing
to use uh upper case characters because
typing in lower case and using
punctuation would be quicker
I maybe it would I don't know what are
these people doing with the rest of
their time I'm very curious building
some app that's going to save the world
maybe I'm going to presume that they're
the people that are using superhuman
which is this
supercharged email app that some people
that seem to send lots of emails use uh
but yeah I think it's super interesting
to think about the
until you have something that you're
going to spend your time doing you're
going to inevitably just fill it with
whatever's the most convenient the path
of least resistance at this great chat
with Ryan holiday about his new book
which is to do with discipline and he
said that unless you have a goal that
you're working toward discipline is
never in service of anything and being
disciplined requires you to posit
yourself against the thing that you're
aiming for like unless you have a goal
what do you what what does discipline
look like your your day could be your
goal could be I want to be the person
that watches the most tick tock on the
planet today therefore the discipline
that you would have in order to achieve
that goal will be very different to the
sort of person that says I want to spend
time outside I want to spend time with
my family and so on and so forth so yes
thinking about what do I actually want
to do if and I think that
I don't know maybe working people
especially parents might feel a bit of
guilt if you said okay let's say that
you had two hours to yourself to do what
you wanted what would you do and if they
come back and give you an answer like uh
I'd love to clean the house I'd love to
get ahead on some of the washing I'd
love to prepare the food for next week
or there's a couple it's like no no no
no I didn't ask you what would be
advantageous to make the remainder of
your time more easy I said what would
you like to do and I know that my mum is
like a really good example of this would
be that would be her kind of answer you
know she would have always been in
service to the household and self-care
and stuff like that would have been
something that she needed to learn over
time so yeah I think
giving yourself license to actually have
things you want to do and then forcing
life around that like the the dishes
will they'll wait
they will wait and and
I mean so in in Tranquility by Tuesday
one of the rules that I had people try
um was to take one night for you and it
was this idea of taking you know two
hours like on a Thursday night to go do
something that does not work it is not
caring for family members it is for you
that you inherently enjoy you
intrinsically enjoy and you know some
people did think like oh I'll you know
spend this time doing chores or
something like that and some people
couldn't even think of what they would
want to do like they just hadn't even
asked themselves their Quest that
question because you get so wrapped up
in all the things you have to do for
work and all the things that need to
happen to run a household and so it's
like it took some time they had to go
back through extracurricular activities
they did in high school like would any
of those be an option now you know or
um when I'm doing something that's feels
Pleasant what is it uh you know
brainstorming looking around at all
sorts of lists and community events and
the like it it takes work imagine this
you know properly using our Leisure Time
takes work but I think it's worthwhile
work I think we should take our Leisure
Time seriously because then we can have
so much of a better time with it yeah
Seth Stevens davidowitz has this great
quote where he says we often confuse a
comfortable activity for a worthwhile
one and that this is your thing right
the path of least resistance resorting
to something which currently wants to do
but future you is going to regret you
doing as opposed to something that
current you might find a tiny bit
difficult but future is going to be very
thankful about so you've got these nine
rules that you go through and you did a
study you ran a study with a big fairly
big sample size of people and you ask
them a bunch of questions and got them
to do all of these different strategies
when it comes to the one which is
spending two hours for yourself on an
evening time
what are you hoping that people are
going to learn from that is it that they
have this ability to kind of move time
and requirements and Urgent stuff around
something which is for their self-care
oh definitely that is one of the things
I want people to learn that they can
make time for the things that they want
to do I mean partly it's just fun right
I want people to have fun
um and so there's that and I want them
to commit to something because when you
make a commitment it actually happens
right so people be like oh I want to
read more I want to take a bubble bath
well you know if your boss wants you to
work late on Thursday night you're not
gonna be like no no I have an
appointment with my bubble bath like
your kid wants you to drive them
somewhere you know like your bathtub
isn't going anywhere you can always push
it forward so then you wind up never
doing it whereas if you are playing on a
softball team like they need a second
baseman you will show up right and and
you will go even if life is busy even if
you're tired even if other people would
you know kind of prefer you did
something else and as a result you will
get the benefit of this more active form
of of self-care
um yeah and you know I wanted them to
see that I wanted them to see also that
the world does keep spinning if they are
not actively attending to professional
or Family Matters for two hours I think
a lot of people have this idea that only
they can do the things they do and you
know it this comes from two places I
mean sometimes it's arrogance like you
know you hear this with people like oh
you just can't hire good employees these
days nobody could ever figure this out
like except me okay fine maybe
um and people do this on the home front
too I mean there's you know forms of
like people thinking you know no
babysitter could ever take care of their
kids even that they don't think their
partner can manage their children right
like this happens all the time it could
be arrogance it can be fear
um which is the flip side of the same
coin that if I allow for the possibility
that I don't have to do everything like
what's the point of me you know if
things can function in my absence what
is the point of me you know point of
view like everyone we all have inherent
worth apart from anything we do which is
very fortunate because the Earth is
going to go on spinning in all of our
absence so it's uh you know better get
our heads around that you know it's like
in a cosmic sense it's true so it's
probably going to be true for you know
two hours on a Tuesday night as well
relinquishing control in that way I I
feel like that's a lesson for all of the
guys that are listening up the people
that don't have kids yet
if you have been a part of a team if
you've been part of a business reflect
on all of the times that you didn't let
anybody else touch the presentation
before it went out this is the exact
same Dynamic I'm speaking to 23 year old
24 year old me who did 210 Saturdays in
a row without a single break setting up
a nightclub that I could have paid some
student
30 pounds to go and do but no no no
because if the the inflatable wasn't
quite over the the lighting rig at the
exact right angle then it was going to
look bad and if it looked bad maybe that
would be the beginning of the end for
the company and like just total
overbearing neuroticism and a lack of
understanding that other people can do
what you do uh and yeah as well a desire
to feel important and and to want to be
the Crux of things and this is very much
I think British people will probably uh
feel a massive Affinity the Puritan work
ethic is it's it's strong strong in the
British people it's a Puritan work ethic
but um yeah so going back to the first
rule which I can't believe that people
don't know but this may be news to
someone that you should give yourself a
bedtime
it you know we should all know it it's
kind of amazing how many people don't do
it though
um you know I've seen a couple memes on
social media lately like one was
somebody saying I would do absolutely
anything to get eight hours of sleep
except go to bed eight hours before I
need to wake up
well
there's an idea we could try that one or
you know it's like uh you know
7 PM me says like oh I'm gonna get I
need to get eight hours of sleep tonight
midnight me whoops there it went to get
you know it's it's just people for many
reasons stay up past when we know we
should but um it's really so much better
to get the amount of sleep that you need
every single night and and often people
are like oh well I I can get by on less
and maybe you can for two nights three
nights but then your body will force you
to make it up like we have a sleep set
point that your body is aiming toward
and if you purposefully skimp on it for
a couple of days eventually you know the
piper must be paid and you will you know
crash somewhere or another it's often
you know sleeping in on weekends but it
could be falling asleep on the couch in
front of the TV it's uh you know
sleeping through alarms it's hitting
snooze three times so all of these are
just ways your body forces you to catch
up on sleep so you're not saving time
you're just moving the time somewhere
else and the question is you know is
staying up between 11 p.m and midnight
like whatever you were doing between 11
pm and midnight was that so much better
than what you would have done in that
other time where your body is forcing
you to catch up on the sleep and most of
the time I'm guessing it probably isn't
um but again you know we need to do it
so
figure out what time you need to wake up
in the morning count back the amount of
sleep you need I generally have to be up
around 6 30 a.m for you know getting my
family ready I need seven and a half
hours of sleep so my bedtime is 11 p.m
that is just a math problem it is
nothing else it is just a statement that
6 30 a.m minus seven and a half hours
gets us to 11 p.m and then you do
something before that to make sure that
you can get yourself into bed on time
you know just
an alarm a note something that you know
30 minutes before so you can wind down
brush your teeth lock the doors whatever
it is you need to do
but I think another part of it I mean
the reason we're staying up is because
that's time we can have for ourselves
right it's you know free time it's like
everything's done you're relaxed you're
like it's Pleasant I have control of my
time I can do what I want who wants to
put it into that but a lot of the other
Tranquility by Tuesday rules are about
giving yourself better Leisure Time at
other points during your day so you
don't have to only get it between 11 and
midnight
first thing in the morning is also
relatively tranquil as well you know
especially if you can push that wake
time a tiny little bit earlier and the
sort of things that you will do at 6am
versus the sort of things that you will
do at 11 PM are going to be very
different in terms of how you're going
to feel about them the next day yeah I
mean
for the people that have never tracked
their sleep using a wearable like whoop
or an eight-sleep mattress or something
you will be disgusted at how little
sleep you get from the amount of time
that you spend in bed now you get it's
it's not half but it's not a hundred
percent and if you get I get somewhere
typically between about 18 85 percent
what's called Sleep efficiency at least
on this app uh and that means that if
I'm in bed for eight hours I can
sometimes get 6 hours and 45 minutes to
6 hours 30 of sleep right
hang on a second I I was in bed I did
the thing I did the thing for eight
hours and you're telling me that I've
got the amount of sleep that Matthew
Walker says is approaching someone
that's pre-diabetic if I keep doing that
for four days in a row like this wasn't
the deal that was made so yeah I think
another thing to add on to this give
yourself a bedtime but I would highly
recommend that people get a wearable for
a little while you get it for Christmas
right and just teach yourself force that
red pill down your throat for 90 days to
learn okay I I actually need to be in
bed for eight hours because if you're in
bed for seven hours
you would easily easily get under six
six hours five and a half hours of sleep
and that's that's like super intense
yeah
sleep efficiency I mean that's probably
just not the way the human body is is
built but that's fine it could be that
you know you have a time in bed and you
have a Target sleep amount and the
target sleep amount may be low it maybe
you know seven hours and your time in
bed is 7 45 or 8 or something like that
or you know but as long as it is not you
know four hours
yeah which would suggest more of a
problem
um it's possible that those two numbers
are are different I do know it's being
in bed for me seven and a half hours is
is what I need to do I'm I fall asleep
pretty quickly I tend to sleep pretty
well I don't think there's a whole lot I
mean I don't think there's a whole lot
of uh not sleeping time but uh you know
different people have different
experiences
plan on Fridays
yeah so this is Tranquility by Tuesday
rule number
and it is about thinking through our
upcoming weeks holistically looking at
all aspects of our life and looking at
the whole week so it accomplishes
encompasses two parts the first and most
important is to plan I think everybody
needs a designated weekly planning time
you need to look forward to the upcoming
week ask yourself what's most important
to me in three dimensions career
relationships self
ask what you want to spend your time
doing ask what you need to spend your
time doing solve any logistical problems
that you can spot when you are looking
at the week as a whole make sure you
have stuff that you are looking forward
to
and you know you just do this week after
week and you can make steady progress
toward your long-term goals because
you're always putting in steps toward
the goals and you know putting a spot on
your calendar for them and that tends to
over time mean you are spending more
time on those things and you're also
feeling more more calm because you're
seeing problems that you wouldn't see if
you're just looking day to day
um so getting out of that day-to-day
mindset is how people see like you know
you've got something huge due on
Thursday
um Wednesday is totally packed you look
at the week as a whole you say oh I
carve out time Monday and Tuesday to
work on the thing that is due Thursday
whereas if you were just going day to
day then Wednesday is either a total
disaster or you don't meet your deadline
on Thursday I mean one of those two
things is what's going to happen so
um we do that so that's the most
important part but the Friday Part uh is
is maybe a little bit more cryptic
I think Friday is a great time for
planning um partly because
at least by Friday afternoon many people
are not raring to go on anything else is
really hard on Friday afternoon to start
making project you know progress toward
your long-term goals I don't say I'm
excited about you know taking on this
new activity right now like but you
might be willing to think what future
you should do so turn what might be
wasted time into some of your most
productive minutes of the week it's
business hours
so if you need to make an appointment
you need to set up a meeting with
someone you're more likely to be
successful in doing that versus Sunday
night which I know is another popular
time for planning it lets you use more
of Monday like if you plan on Monday
morning you're not going to really get
going on stuff until later in the day
Monday and set up meetings if you can't
do them then you know it's going to be
Tuesday and again if we're sliding into
the weekend on Friday I think we've just
massively shortened our week so to use
all of Monday you plan on Friday
um but sort of the deepest reason is you
know even people who really love their
jobs can start feel a little trepidation
on Sunday night if they don't know
what's waiting for them on Monday
morning and you know you got all this
stuff you don't know how you're going to
deal with it if you leave Friday
afternoon with a plan for Monday then
you can actually enjoy your time off
because you're good like you solved that
problem you know what it's on your plate
you've got your marching orders and I
find that really helps people relax
I very much like the idea of getting
ahead of the week
functionally what have you got a
worksheet I know that you've got
worksheets for other things if you've
got a worksheet for Friday afternoons on
your website
I don't but it's
not what does it look like what does the
what is the precise process look like um
for years I was just using a notebook
from Target and I would put my career
stuff on the left side of the page
and you know the relationships and
personal stuff kind of on the right side
of the page
look at my calendar for the upcoming
week and just list
you know what do I want to do in these
categories and it wouldn't be long like
I you know the notebook is small and I
don't want to go over a page uh so that
forces a little bit of um Reckoning
about what can actually fit in a week
and you know what is truly most
important I'm not putting stuff like you
know get kids to school every day or you
know random stuff with my job like you
know those aren't things that go on
there uh it's it's more
out of the ordinary sort of stuff or
steps toward long-term goals so as an
example I'm running a 5k with my oldest
child on Thanksgiving I run regularly he
does not he needs to start doing that
with me we need to carve out one time I
mean he's he's gonna be faster than me
he just needs to like actually run a few
times before this happens you know we
were out of practice so you know we need
to carve out at least one time in the
next week to do a run together so I've
got that on the list like that's a
family priority for the upcoming week
and so that you know this isn't a crisis
when we get to Thanksgiving he's like
Mom I can't do it like you know if we're
gonna do it together like we take the
steps toward the toward the goals there
um so it's stuff like that move by 3 pm
so this is
this exercise needs to be it doesn't
need to be an hour in the gym that
leaves you covered in sweat uh it
doesn't have to involve any equipment
physical activity in and of itself is
good for the human body we are built to
move far more than we truly do
um so we need to be in the habit of
moving every single day
and so I suggest you know build this
habit by 10 minutes of physical activity
at some point before 3 pm each day and
you say well I work out in the evening I
go to the gym after work that's awesome
like you keep doing that but you could
still take a 10 minute walk break at
some point during your work day before 3
P.M and in fact that would be a really
really good idea
um because you know many jobs involve
sitting and many jobs feel like they
could be done just sort of back to back
to back going one thing to the next but
everyone takes breaks in some shape you
know or form It's just sometimes they're
unintentional I'm telling people to take
an intentional break to do something
that is pretty much guaranteed to boost
your mood and boost your energy levels
look at your day strategically see where
you can squeeze it in you'll get the
benefit of the exercise of course but
you also get the benefit benefit of that
strategic thinking if you're looking at
your day as a whole seeing where the
space could go and it was that strategic
mindset which as much as anything is
what I was trying to teach people with
this role the more that I spend time
around guys like Aaron Alexander that
does the Align podcast and Ben
Greenfield
it I think that the next big Fitness
movement is going to be Beyond
Progressive overloads and weightlifting
and Zone 2 cardio and like sort of the
stuff that most people understand and
into
your body is like a battery it needs to
be exposed to the elements it needs to
see sunlight it needs to enter your eyes
you need to get some time in and around
nature that would be good for you you
need to be near grass some of the
research is a bit woo for me at the
moment but the guys that are starting to
come to the four seem to be more
evidence-based which gives me more
belief in it and from an end of one
total anecdote I feel better when I do
that stuff so yeah I mean it blows my
mind that we have to say and don't get
me wrong I've gone through
there was there would have been months
of me during my 20s where I wouldn't
have moved by 3 pm and what I would have
thought is well yeah but I'm going to go
and annihilate myself for 90 minutes
later on I'm gonna go and lift heavy
things with my friends with loud music
playing so I fixed it that's not that's
not really health or Fitness that's just
lifting weight such as bodybuilding or
whatever
like Pursuit you're going after so yeah
I think a more holistic view of what it
means to move uh is something that I
would be very very surprised if we don't
see like completely on the ascendancy
soon and then talking about habits three
times a week is a habit what's that mean
yeah so this is about a mindset shift
um of many people when they have things
they want to do in their lives their
first thought is I should be doing it
daily
um and you know that's how a lot of
people think about habits like oh this
is gonna be my daily habit but the truth
is even people who have
really good habits in life often they
don't do them daily I mean one of the
occupational hazards of writing about
time management people always want to
tell me about their great daily habits
and I talk to them a little bit more and
I find that they often meet Monday
through Friday
but that's not daily that is five times
a week right so you know we're still
under seven we're not a daily like you
know you might consider it a very
frequent part of your life but it isn't
every single day so the question is then
well how many days does it have to be to
be you know an important part of your
life and I I think three is a defensible
number it's often it's just not always
and it's often a very doable number
um so I when I ask people in my project
to think about things that they wanted
to have in their lives more frequently
and I asked them to think about when was
the last time you did this like the
majority had done it in the last week
and an even bigger majority had done it
within the last month like these are
things people do sometimes the question
is how can we go from sometimes to
regularly and I think aiming for three
times a week tends to be doable because
if you're already doing something once a
week getting to three is not that hard
right you're just saying how can I do
this twice more like at some point in my
life in the whole of seven days can I
find two more spots and that is a very
doable thing and then you're the person
who's doing it regularly it can be part
of your identity so what are we talking
about here I mean it could be a formal
workout like going to lift weights right
that would be something that you might
aim to do three times a week it could be
you know practicing a musical instrument
doing that three times a week in a busy
life would be enough to have it feel
like it is part of your identity you
know you are somebody who plays the
guitar you are somebody who is regularly
playing the piano or singing your skills
or whatever it happens to be uh you know
it might be something like practicing a
foreign language it might be something
you know relationship based like getting
one-on-one time with family members or
eating family meals together it could be
connecting with your partner in some way
shape or form
um any of any of these things would make
excellent three times a week sort of
things and sure there are some things
that should be done daily right like are
moving by 3 P.M I it should happen every
single day but the things that are going
to happen daily need to be very small
because in general in life it is hard to
do something every single day I have
done a few streaks of various points in
my life um because I'm obsessed with
streaks I find them fascinating but I
can also tell you it can wind up being
something that you then have to schedule
a lot of your life around to make sure
that it happens every single day
allowing for three times a week is just
more doable for so many people when
something is doable then we do it as
opposed to sort of lamenting that it
can't be part of our Lives which is what
happens when people aim for daily but
the perfect is the enemy of done right
well yeah perfect is the enemy of the
good perfect is the enemy have done only
for perfect it's just a problem why is
the identity thing a component here why
is that you mentioned a couple of times
you can call yourself a
footballer softballer guitar player why
is that a contributor
you know caring for family members or
anything you need to do there there is
this other aspect to you that is a
different
a different identity to use that word
again and and this is you know how
people get their self-image too right
like you know it's something that you
can feel more control over more autonomy
you can see progress in all of those
things are associated with well-being
um and and so you know I found that
people especially in what I call the
Busy years of people you know are
building their careers raising their
families they do wind up often feeling
like they don't have the identity they
wish to have like they're they're
missing that component and so you know
whatever it is having that be part of
your life you know part of your life
story this is something I make space for
regularly
um Can can make you feel more like you
are making time for what matters my
favorite rule from Atomic Habits by
James Clear is never miss two days in a
row
and that is exactly the same as what
you're talking about here you know three
times a week is an acceptable habit and
three times a week also happens to line
up with never miss two days in a row
well I think you might miss two once
right if you do three what are you gonna
do Monday Wednesday Friday and then
you'd Miss Saturday Sunday and do Monday
Wednesday Friday James come on now but
yeah
it works for people too you know then
you do it four times a week right then
you'd never miss two days in a while if
you want to aim for that like the exact
number doesn't matter it's more that you
want a doable number and I think for
many people three is is probably more
doable than aiming for four or five yes
also the momentum as well of having a
minimum viable whatever it is it's so
strange I see in myself as I've started
to try and do new stuff with a new
lifestyle out here in Austin trying to
build new habits having been the person
that's harped on about you know minimum
viable and just one push-ups enough and
stuff like that but ego gets in the way
and ego tries to tell you well yeah but
if it's not if I can't get the optimal
amount and maybe I should do a bit of
research about how much pickleball I
actually should be playing and now if I
can't get in there for a full hour
what's the point of going for 15 minutes
uh and the
bottom line I think is intentionality
again like look just what did you say
what did you say was a good rule good
rule was to just do it if you can to
just do it and just get it done do it
all right create a backup slot
yes so we need resilient schedules I
mean people get very frustrated that
they make plans to spend time
intervenes
um and the more sort of moving Parts you
have in your life the more likely that
life will intervene
um that you know you might want to meet
with an employee at work to talk about
the great things they're doing and then
you know right before you're supposed to
meet there's some huge client crisis or
on your personal front you're trying to
get together with a friend that you
haven't seen in a while and then you
know something happens one of you get
sick or there's you know a work of
urgency for one of you or whatever and
these things get very frustrating like I
wanted to make it happen I did my best
life intervene so
what we need is if people have been
invited to outdoor events
you know that often on the invitation it
says a rain date and this is really just
a great scheduling concept if you think
about it the organizers are
acknowledging that much can go
predictably wrong with outdoor events
like it's right there in the rain date
name but there's no question of whether
the event will be rescheduled or for
when
it will be on the rain date and so if
you want to go to this event you won't
put anything unmovable in the second
slot and by having a rain date you
vastly increase the chances that the
event happens even if not when
originally planned and so if something
is important to you in life you need a
rain date for it right you need a time
where if you're meeting with an employee
you wouldn't you know he both know when
this is going to get rescheduled to if
the first time doesn't happen if you and
your friend are planning to get together
Tuesday night you know and it's been
planned for a long time you really want
to make it happen and why not say it
look I want to make Tuesday happening
for some reason it doesn't happen we are
automatically going to reschedule for
next Tuesday
why not why not do that like right that
that just vastly increases the chances
that it happens that you get together
with your friends now I it can get
unwieldy to create designated rain dates
for everything
um so you know for for sort of life in
general it helps to just have more open
space because then you can put things in
the open space when life doesn't go as
planned so if some emergency bumps one
of your priorities earlier you know you
put that priority in the open space if
some great opportunity comes up you have
spots to put it because you have not
booked every single minute and and I
actually find that having that open
space allows you to be more open to
opportunity you're not pushing it away
because you have no time for it right
you're you're sort of like yeah you know
stuff comes I'll I'll read that email
from the person I didn't know to see you
know what they have to say or
um you know your friend mentions getting
together and you're like I've got open
space to do it and then you have a
conversation that leads to something
really productive like open space allows
those things to have happen
um so we need to have open space in our
lives and that's what gives us resilient
schedules have you found a correlation
between how busy successful people's
schedules are and how successful the
successful people are well I mean I
think everyone has a different
impression because I'm sure there are
plenty of people who you know call
themselves successful and are successful
that you know have booked themselves
solid right like you know it's fine we
all have different approaches I do think
though especially
um you know a lot of the people who wind
up reading my books and listening to my
podcasts are women who have kids and
also have jobs and I think I write for
everyone but I found that one of my
things that draws people to my work is I
have acknowledged that stuff can go
wrong that is totally not your fault
that keeps you from doing productive
things and you need a plan for it I mean
there's a lot of you know the tech Bros
or others you know who have never had a
child care crisis in their life like
they don't understand the idea that you
could have a huge day full of meetings
and like your babysitter could call in
sick like they do not even get the
concept that could happen and yet a lot
of people that is their life and so it's
like you know thinking about well what
can I do like well I need backup child
care options I also need backup slots so
if I cannot get to something on one day
where can it go so I'm still a reliable
person who meets my obligations
um in a timely manner and I you know a
lot of my audience needs to think about
that and you know it's it's it's how you
make life work
um so yeah I'm I'm I think that some
people can get away with a little bit
less open space but the more moving
Parts you have in your life probably the
more space you need one big adventure
one little Adventure
so this is
[Music]
this the same day-to-day a lot of people
have the experience you know get up get
ready for work you work you you know get
to the end of the day you have dinner
watch TV go to bed
um and you do this day after day after
day and it's fine there's nothing wrong
with routines because routines make good
choices automatic but when too much
stingness sucks up like all of the it
feels like whole years are disappearing
into these memory sinkholes where you
know nothing exists to you know
distinguish one day one week one year
from another
and the solution to this is to start
putting in some memorable things and one
big adventure one little Adventure is to
have two Adventures each week a big
adventure is three to four hours half a
weekend day a little Adventure could be
less than an hour you know doable on a
lunch break doable on a weekday evening
as long as it's out of the ordinary
and this is a pace that is not going to
exhaust or bankrupt anyone like if you
like to come home from work and get in
your pajamas four out of five days you
can do just that you know if you like to
spend your weekends on the couch that is
totally fine you just take three hours
to do something other than being on the
couch okay you know it's not going to
exhaust or bankrupt anyone but it will
change your entire experience of time
partly because you start looking for
things to do you start being on the
lookout for Adventures like you become
an adventurous person as part of your
identity you're the one who's looking
for that fun thing to do and you also
just create so many more memories and
and our perception of how much time we
have is uh influenced by how many
memories we have of Any Given unit of
time so the more memories we have of a
particular stretch of time the longer it
feels like it was uh and and so this is
creating more memories it's like not
just another week that was like every
week it was like no that's the week that
we went mini golfing that's the week we
went for that hike in the state park to
see the changing leaves that's the week
we tried that new place that serves the
excellent hot chocolate
these are all the things that would make
this week different from all other weeks
that Insight of trying to create novelty
and variety and intensity in order to
make life feel like it goes slower is
something that I've kept
what three years ago three and a half
years ago I think was the first time
you're on the show I keep on spouting on
about that you know why is it that life
continues to seem like it's going
quicker as I get older I know that I at
times literally we have
formula that tell us that time doesn't
change its speed like at least your
subjective passage of time can do but
the objective passage of time doesn't
and yeah that I think that's so such a
good way to look at things I suppose as
well if you've got
Little Adventures planned out even
further ahead you can enjoy the
anticipation of those as they're coming
up Tim Ferriss has got this idea about
having at least four holidays booked in
at once he's got holidays booked in for
2025 and 2026 and stuff like that
because he wants there is a good amount
of joy that you take from the
anticipation of going away and doing a
trip or something and you can get
excited with your friends and research
the cafe that you're going to go to or
whatever
no I mean I'm all about anticipation I
mean I think you know it can be hard to
do more than a year out for various
reasons um you know I've I've had the
experience personally of uh you know
thinking I'd do something in in a year
and then you know it's at the same time
that we've been like building our family
I have five kids now and you know you
wind up like with a newborn it's like
probably that thing isn't happening so I
don't know it's a different experience I
guess but uh you know it I I do think
that
um making life memorable is a worthwhile
Endeavor and that the reason yeah as we
get older it seems that time is
accelerating is because we're not
putting ourselves outside of our comfort
zone at all like you know that's great
with adult life we get to do what we
want to do like you don't have to do
things that you don't I mean it's kind
of a privilege of adulthood in some ways
but uh you know one of the reasons
people remember high school and college
young adulthood so much is because there
was so much that was new it was you know
first jobs moving to New cities meeting
new new people you know new
relationships that you know and
obviously you're not going to do that
hopefully you know if you're settled
with someone you're not starting new
relationships but you need to think
about ways that you can make things feel
more novel and intense and maybe a
little bit less in your comfort zone and
it can be hard in the moment right like
future us is gonna be happy we did it
current US kind of wants to sit on the
couch right
um but but thinking about future us and
having that picture of ourselves on the
other side
can be really helpful in nudging that
little action for it and you know often
Adventures are enjoyable things I mean
it takes a little bit of effort to get
going but then you're gonna have fun
while you're doing it you're gonna make
the memories and you can look back on
that afterwards and be grateful that you
know the current you did decide to not
just sit there what advice would you
give to people who struggle with
discipline when it comes to those
situations that have the choice between
the comfy couch and the adventure that
they promised themselves and they need I
know a mantra or a philosophy or
somewhere firm to stand that they can
push off of in that situation
yeah there's a couple things you can do
I mean the most simple is just you know
have this mantras uh plan it in do it
anyway
so if you planned it in it's because you
thought you would enjoy it
um and
so given that you thought you would when
you were making the plan there's a
pretty good chance that you will it's
just you have to overcome that slight
inertia to do it
you can also ask am I going to be happy
to have this as a memory
and if you would like if you can say you
know I would probably like to you know
three hours from now look back on saying
wow that was such a beautiful hike
through that park with all the changing
fall leaves you know if if you're going
to be happy to have that memory then
picture yourself having that memory and
in the service of that memory go do that
thing right uh you're still gonna have
down time like this is the part that you
know people like well I want to relax I
mean you're gonna relax like there is
always unstructured time it's just a
question of like are you gonna spend all
day doing that are you gonna have a
couple hours to do this other thing and
then have your unstructured time
afterwards having had the memory of
doing something different with your time
I love those I think that's really
really important and I think that that's
a sticking point A lot of people are
going to find themselves at so yes both
very very useful okay batch the little
things
yeah so this is about creating more open
space in our lives for the things that
we want to spend time doing I think many
people having have the experience of
feeling like the little things in life
are just sucking up all your brain space
um you know these are small tasks at
work you got to fill out that form for
HR you got to respond to these
non-urgent messages you got to set up
that we you know meeting for two weeks
from now it's like you have to do these
things
but they don't really have to get done
urgently
or on the home front you know people
like I have to order light bulbs I have
to fill out that permission slip for a
kid or whatever it is and it can feel
like you're spending all your time on
these things each thing probably doesn't
take that much time but but you know if
you're spreading them out over your
entire schedule you can be spending your
life on the Medusa and feeling like you
have no time for either deeper work or
relaxing so the solution is to batch all
these things into short windows of time
so for instance you could say you know
in the afternoon between 1 30 and 2 15
I'm going to tackle all these little
tasks I have for today
um and and what that allows you to do
is you know spend your deeper work time
in the morning on other things right you
you don't have to be like oh well I was
going to be working on this project but
okay I gotta get to that form for HR
like no no there's a time for that now
is not that time but even more
importantly and I think this is uh you
know this this comes up a lot is
a lot of those little tasks are very
effective tools for
information like you're like well I I'm
supposed to be doing this hard project
thinking about where my business is
going and writing up this solution for
this and I oh but I could go order that
birthday present on Amazon
and the birthday present it's done it's
you cross it off the list like it feels
like you accomplished something even
though really it was just distracting
you from from something that you should
have been putting your effort into so
um you know by batching the little
things you also deprive yourself of some
of those easy wins so that you are going
to force yourself to try to get the
bigger wins
um knowing that there's a time you know
that you are going to get all those easy
wins together
one of the most uncomfortable
realizations is knowing that almost
everything that's on your to-do list
probably doesn't move you that much
closer to your goals and that there is
one thing today that might contribute 50
to things that will probably contribute
to 20 and then everything else is maybe
even less maybe maybe it's even more
toward that first one and uh yeah you
you flip the bar stool upside down and
try to sit on it in a desperate attempt
to make yourself feel like you're being
productive are there any other things
when it comes to to-do list
creation management writing are there
any other big no-nos or errors that you
see people making people people make
their to-do lists too long that there's
anything it's a wish list anything in
the planet that they might wish to do at
some point or another there's no order
to it there's no sense of urgency to it
there's no sense of what is important
now and what is not and so of course you
don't get through everything but if
you've got 50 items on your to-do list
you know you get through seven like the
problem is were those seven the things
that you meant to do to it like you
really should have done today or were
they not
um whereas if you consciously choose
only seven things to do today and you
get through those seven things well you
feel wonderfully accomplished and like
you know that those were the things that
you set out to do and you you did them
and you know there's no virtue in
putting something on a to-do list and
then not doing it it just is not done if
you as if you never put it on the list
in the first place but you know now you
feel bad because it's sitting there
uncrossed off and you push it to the
next day and push it to the next day so
on in eternum so
um better to think of the to-do list
more as a contract with yourself
that if you're putting something on the
to-do list for the day or the week you
really truly intend to do it and in
order for that to be true given that as
we noted life comes up it's got to be
short like there's no way around it you
can't fill all available space it has to
be shorter than the available space
because stuff will come up and it has to
be you know very focused so I think
that's that's a better way of doing
to-do lists effortful before effortless
which is my favorite one of the list oh
good well this is the last one on the
list this is Rule Number Nine and
Tranquility by Tuesday and this is about
how we spend our Leisure Time so even
the busiest people have some amount of
leisure time but the problem is that a
lot of it is short in duration it is
uncertain in duration you know you don't
know are you gonna have five minutes 10
minutes 15 minutes
it happens during low energy times so
you know at night after you're done with
work done with your chores
that is the leisure time you have and
you know screen time
fills all these constraints incredibly
well like you can be on Twitter for two
minutes or 20 minutes or two hours it
doesn't really matter like we'll take
all that time whatever you want to give
it
um you know you don't need to plan ahead
or you know make plans with friends or
anything like in order to watch Netflix
um you don't need to expend a whole lot
of energy it's not making any demands of
you
and because of these
attributes of screen time it winds up
filling the bulk of our Leisure Time and
there's nothing wrong with that like I
like social media and I like television
there's a lot of good stuff on the
problem is that in the abstract many
people would like to spend some of their
Leisure Time on other things right they
would like to spend some of their
Leisure Time on those things that we
always say we don't have time for like
reading Hobbies connecting with friends
and so in order to make more space for
those things we have to start
repurposing some of these smaller bits
of leisure and some of these low energy
times of leisure so one of the best ways
you can do this is to challenge yourself
to do just a few minutes of effortful
fun before effortless fun
so if you've got a spot of time you're
about to pick up your phone
open you know one of the e-reading apps
like read an ebook for two minutes and
then you can go to Twitter right or if
you are you know putting the kids in bed
or you've you know finished your chores
or whatever it is and you're about to
watch Netflix like do a puzzle for 10
minutes and then go watch Netflix
and one of two things will happen like
often people get so into their effortful
fun that they just keep going with it
right they want to find out what
happened in that book like they're
seeing the puzzle take shape you know
they're making progress in their Hobbies
it's very exciting they stick with it
um and that's great because Facebook
will still be there whenever you come
back to it uh but even if you don't
you've switched the balance
and so you have at least some more of
that high quality leisure time in your
life than you would have had before and
that tends to make people feel more
satisfied with their leisure time and it
also tends to make them notice it I mean
many people don't even notice those
small you know screen checks during the
day they don't notice how much time they
might have at night before they go to
bed that they could devote to various
sorts of leisure but when you are
actively choosing some of these more
effortful forms of fun
it's hard to not notice it and so your
narrative becomes like I do have free
time I do have Leisure Time I can make
time for these things and and it changes
our entire perception of what life is
like
I very much like to think about
little approaches like that where you
can
every single time you go to go and do
something
you slot an additional bit of friction
in beforehand so you can also do this I
suppose in Reverse which is that if you
want to do something which is effortless
you could make it more effortful so I
have if I try and use my phone after 8
pm on the night I'm supposed to stand up
when I want to use it so I have to go
and do it but I'm like okay I'm stood up
but you're not on the couch yeah
precisely yeah because the more
sedentary that you are the longer that
you're going to stay on the phone and
you know that the phone after 8 PM I
mean I'm on CST and a ton of my friends
were in the UK and if I'm not out with
people in the US nothing good is
happening on my phone after 8 PM right
so it's like okay well let's add a
little bit of friction in that the same
thing goes for doing little little bits
and pieces of work as well when it comes
to combining all of these rules together
I know that you had a process that
people went through and they sort of
batched them and stuff
I'm going to guess that trying to do all
of these at once might be a little
overwhelming and a little too much is
there a protocol that people should
follow when it comes to trying to
introduce these yeah so so when I did
this project I had 150 people try out
these rules over nine weeks and what I
did is each rule I would introduce each
week right so each week they would learn
a new rule
um they would then answer questions
about how they plan to implement it they
would follow up a week later with
questions on how it went and I went in a
certain order the first one is to give
yourself a bedtime precisely because
Everything feels easier when you're
getting enough sleep the second one is
to plan on Fridays and that's because
then you can see your week and think
where you might do things like plan an
open space and plan an adventures and
all these sorts of things right so
there's an order to it
um and what I have people do is they
would learn a learn the rule and then
add another one and then add another one
so hopefully the first one is starting
to feel a little bit more ingrained by
the time you start the next one and then
you know you remind yourself to do both
of them so as you're building that you
add in the third one and and so forth
and you know you don't have to do this
like I mean if it sounded appealing to
you to try the effortful before
effortless fun like go ahead and do that
first you know there's nothing wrong
with doing that you can certainly try
that at any point that you like but yeah
I do think that trying to adopt all nine
habits at you know the exact same moment
might be a little bit overwhelming uh so
you know maybe maybe try doing it a week
at a time and see how it goes and some
of them might take a little bit longer
to become habits you might have to
remind yourself of some of them a little
bit more as you're going through but you
know that's like anything it takes some
time to develop habits and to make them
stick
um so you know over time hopefully that
will happen Laura Von to come ladies and
gentlemen if people want to check out
the stuff that you do online where
should they go you can come visit my
website which is lauravandercam.com you
can learn about Tranquility by Tuesday
and all my other books there learn about
my podcasts I have a short every weekday
morning one called before breakfast
that's just a daily tip to help take
your day from great to awesome
um and so yeah come visit me there we
have a great comment section on my blog
I'm still blogging I love blogging so
love to hear from people there thanks
Laura thanks so much for having me
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
[Music]